let's go to the phones the phone lines
are on fire 617 830 4750 is the number
would go to our first caller from the
773 area code caller what's your name
where are you calling from and what's on
your mind I'll be my name is Jaden I'll
zalando hey Jerry shallow thinking oh oh
don't push a goggle bro Irish wanna
stick then you say oh man I hear a lot
of stuff that Trump is talking about you
know sending in the Fed miss man yoga
and i'm going to say one thing about the
white people in Chicago okay one thing I
feel woke up I feel more comfortable
point out south my grandfather even
service to it feels more comfortable
going down south they're getting around
the white people in connecting up as
part of the city and I had pursued in
Chicago and if you knew the racism that
a lot of these people at it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable it's like
certain like my neighborhood is phenom
ii Irish it's like I can't walk to
certain parts of me that might make my
neighborhood I just did my ass beat just
be real with you I'm not asking
everybody's bad but it's just like if
it's a funny situation because even if
you're even if you're white if certain
neighborhoods can't walk too well listen
I mean that sounds similar to you know
the neighborhood I live in in Boston is
called South Boston and that's a
historically Irish and Italian
neighborhood it's a neighborhood that
over different times has been hostile to
people who aren't white including also
people who are white but are not part of
the Irish or Italian communities it's
you know the different cities have have
these situations i can't speak too much
to what's going on in chicago having
only been there a few times and not
being super familiar but it's
interesting i mean how can i tell you
you're wrong for feeling the way you do
i appreciate you letting us know what I
was let me know man I just want to like
tell you you know I like so anything
that big watch it oh I don't know how
much time i had but i just can't worry
it's like a personal story all right
well listen it's an interesting story i
appreciate you calling
and I hope to talk to you again